[Music]
think for a moment
about a hot dog
what comes to mind
let me be the first to tell you that i
think the concept of a hot dog is
absolutely revolting
pink
rubbery mystery meat in a long tube-like
shape that makes you wonder
is it really food
that most of us drench in ketchup
mustard sometimes relish to mask the
strange salt-laden flavor
but
believe it or not
i love hot dogs
eating a hot dog pulls at my
heartstrings to eat a hot dog is to hang
out with my family at a baseball game
it's a barbecue with friends in the
backyard and here in the u.s it's
celebrating american independence on the
4th of july
when i think of a hot dog i think of
family i think of friends i think of fun
my name is adrian carrister and i love
meat
but i also care deeply about our planet
and i'm concerned about the meat
industry's impact on our environment
after all the meat industry is the
leading cause of deforestation
of water contamination of air pollution
and of soil biodiversity loss
it is also responsible for more than
one-fifth of global greenhouse gas
emissions which is more than all of
transportation combined
because of this i have tried to cut meat
out of my diet not once but five times
and i have failed
every time
i've heard countless stories of
individuals who after watching
one of the many
harrowing documentaries about the meat
industry have cut meat entirely out of
their diet exclaiming triumphantly
and then
i never ate meat ever again
was something wrong with me
i turned to you my stanford classmates
for some help answering this question
over 50 percent of you half of this room
have tried to cut meat out of your diet
before and only a fraction of you have
stuck with it
i'm not here today to tell you to cut
meat out of your diet
it's not effective and people don't like
being told what to do
i'm here today to give you the meat
lover's guide to environmentally
conscious eating which i will do in two
ways
first by diagnosing our love for meat
why is it that we eat meat so much
and
second
by inspiring individual action sharing
with you some tips of ways that we can
collectively reduce our meat consumption
and cut our carbon footprint
and convincing you that your individual
action
does in fact matter
all right
let's diagnose our love for me
like a typical consultant
i send out a survey and i crunch the
numbers
here are the top three reasons why we
love and eat meat
reason number one
it's the default
over 80 percent of you shared with me
that you eat meat because it's the
default option
it's easy it's available
it's what your friends serve when they
host you for dinner it's embedded in
your holiday traditions it's featured in
the entrees at the restaurants you
frequent
the list goes on
for me
meat is central to my notion of what
makes a complete meal
growing up
family dinner was a daily sacred ritual
every evening around 7 30 pm
my family of four would gather around
the table to share a meal and debrief
the day
my memories of these dinners are deeply
defined
by my dad's dinner music
dim lighting
candles
good conversation
and my mom's absolutely delicious
homemade meals
that were well-rounded and often
followed a simple equation
a meat-based main with two sides starch
and greens
today family dinners are typically
vegetarian and my notion of what makes a
meal has evolved but i find that i have
to work extremely hard to fight this
default bias
until we position plant-based options as
the default and reposition meat as a
secondary or a side or even a specialty
option
meat will always be the go-to
reason number two it's all about the
protein
over 70 percent of you shared with me
that you eat meat because it's a high
protein option
and you're not wrong
however
we don't need nearly as much protein as
we think
in fact the average american
eats over a hundred grams of protein a
day which is roughly
double the recommended amount
this fact
doesn't shock me
after all the diet industry pours
millions of dollars into convincing us
that protein is the beacon of health and
wellness
but it did make me wonder
what foods could i eat to get my
recommended 50 grams of protein a day
sands meat
it's actually really quite easy
for example instead of eating two
servings of chicken one at lunch and one
at dinner we could eat two eggs at lunch
and
spinach feta chickpea salad with some
almonds at dinner
we don't need to rely on meat as our
main source of protein
and finally reason number three we still
don't really love the alternatives
over 50 percent of you shared with me
that you eat meat not because you love
it
but because the alternatives are
too expensive too carb heavy
too greasy and sometimes just too bland
so what can we do
at the beginning of this presentation i
shared with you that i'd provide the
meat lover's guide to environmentally
conscious eating
if you love meat but you want to reduce
your carbon footprint and help save our
planet what can you do
where can you start and
does it even matter
while there is no one size fits all
option i want to challenge each of you
to do three things this week
better meet in smaller portions
less frequently
why better meat
it turns out that not all meat is
created equal
beef and lamb are significantly more
harmful to the environment than chicken
or turkey
if you do
purchase red meat
look for options that are certified
organic
or pasture raised
to
support meat production systems that
don't use environmentally harmful
pesticides that contaminate our water
or ruin soil biodiversity
smaller portions
i challenge all of you to rethink your
notion of what makes a meal and try meat
as a side or a topping instead of a main
the usda recommends a serving size of
just three ounces of meat per meal which
to put in context
is about a third of the size of the
chicken breast that you see typically at
trader joe's or safeway
if you're out to eat
try splitting a meat based entree with a
friend in addition to a vegetarian
or a fish entree
finally eat meat less frequently
the best thing you can do for the
environment and for your long-term
health is to reduce the number of meals
you eat containing meat
i challenge all of you to pick just one
day each week to dedicate to being
meatless
meatless mondays have grown in
popularity across the country and around
the world
as someone who loves the social and
cultural aspects of eating meat
i actually don't prescribe to meatless
mondays on a regular basis but i don't
cook meat at home anymore
this shift has allowed me to drastically
reduce my meat consumption from nearly
daily to now only a fraction of my meals
if you take just one thing away from
this presentation
let it be this
if everyone in the u.s were to not eat
meat for just one day each week it would
be the same as not driving 91 billion
miles
which if you do the math is basically
the same as not driving from san
francisco all the way to new york and
back
15 million times
small changes at scale
really do add up to make a difference
so
i'll leave you with this
better meat
in smaller portions
less frequently
this is something we can do as
individuals
with our families and role model for our
organizations
together with these small changes we
really can make a big difference
[Applause]
[Music]